joining us now from Baltimore dr. tom
ingoldsby director of the Center for
Health security at Johns Hopkins
University dr. I know you watched the
rally last night from a public health
standpoint if not a political one I
guess the good news was there wasn't as
big a crowd as expected but as an
epidemiologist watching that rally last
night what did you say
yeah I thought that the rally was
concerning in terms of public health
risk
I think CDC's recent guidance was that
the highest risk gatherings are those
that are large indoors where people
can't stay apart from each other more
than six feet and where people travel
from out of town and this rally met all
of those criteria and what I saw was
that people were sitting quite close to
each other didn't see very many people
wearing masks there were some people
handshaking without hand sanitizer lots
of shouting all of those things will
increase the risk of spread given all of
that does the president's rally in Tulsa
have the potential to be a super
spreader of the virus we have seen in
the past few months around the world
that indoor gatherings have been the
source of most super spreading events
and those are events where one person
can give it to give the virus to many
people there's an opportunity for much
more spread in a short period of time so
I am worried about that I know that many
people in the public health community
are worried about the potential for a
big spreading event I want to pick up on
that because a number of conservatives
point out that a lot of the media and
even some public health experts not you
but some of your colleagues didn't
express the same concerns when there
were tens of thousands of people taking
to the streets in protests over the
death of George Floyd many of them not
wearing masks is is there some hypocrisy
where public health concerns depend upon
the politics of the gathering that's
being held
well they shouldn't depend on the
gathering that's being held I think the
public health principles are the same
whether it's for one purpose or another
I certainly sympathize with the
motivations of the the demonstrations
that have gone on across the country but
I do worry that they are an opportunity
for spread I think it's a little bit it
were even more than a little bit
different than having a large indoor
gathering we know that outdoor risks are
less than indoor risks and if people can
maintain their space then that will help
but certainly I think there is a risk
with large-scale protesting as well for
increased spread let me ask you about
that because there has been some testing
a protester is after the big events in
Minneapolis and New York and at least so
far and I understand the incubation
period goes on there has not been any
clear spike detected as a result of
those is it possible the public health
experts are exaggerating the risk from
these big public gatherings I don't
think they're exaggerating the risks I
do think again that it's it's we know
from what we've seen so far in the last
few months that outdoors is less of a
risk than indoors and that masks use has
a major impact so to the extent that
people are wearing masks in a particular
gathering that will help a lot and it is
also a little bit too soon to say
whether or not the protests have led to
increased cases although I am very glad
to see that the initial studies do show
that there doesn't seem to be an
increased rate of spread it's quite
different in an indoor setting where
people are sitting shoulder to shoulder
for a prolonged period of time and
really in close quarters like that every
time you come on I ask you where are we
with the coronavirus cases and I want to
put up a map that shows the fact that
while there are significant decreases in
a lot of the places that were hit
earliest and hardest there are now 21
states in the West and in the South that
are seeing at least a 20
5% increase in new cases dr. Inglesby
how much of that do you think is just
the fact that we're testing more people
how much of that do you think is the
fact that maybe we're reopening too soon
and how much of that do you think is
that there is in fact a spread a spike
in the virus in some of these states
where there has been reopening I think
it's a combination of more testing and a
real and important spike in many cases
in many in many states across the
country and you can distinguish what is
what is more testing from what is more
serious disease from looking at
hospitalization rate ICU rate and the
percent positivity of the overall tests
in a given state and in many states in
the ones that you just showed
particularly Arizona Texas the Carolinas
Florida what we're seeing is increased
positivity and testing and in many cases
increased hospitalizations so serious
illness happening that's not just
because we're doing more testing in a
state that's because there is more
serious disease in the state so that's a
rise do you think some of them in real
speed you think some of those states
doctor should should pull back on the
reopening should should you know if
they're in phase two go back to phase
one or even go back into partial
lockdowns I I don't think we need to go
into lockdown in these places at this
point I think each state it has a
different story each state has its own
reopening process and they're all
slightly different I do think that
governor's should be guiding their their
public to avoid large gatherings where
we see the the greatest potential risk
they should also be really strongly
encouraging people leaders should be
encouraging people to use the tools that
we know work we should be encouraging
people to wear face coverings to stay at
a distance to avoid large gatherings to
use hand sanitizer or wash your hands I
mean those are things that we know work
and leaders really should having double
down and communicating that across the
country those are the things that we
have seen work and will work
President Trump talked this week about
the virus the spread of the virus and
also about medical treatments here he is
on that we're very close to a vaccine
and we're very close to therapeutics
really good therapeutics and but even
without that I don't even like to talk
about that because it's fading away it's
going to fade away is the corona virus
fading away are we close very close to a
vaccine and the World Health
Organization said this week that we are
in a let me get it right a new and
dangerous phase of kovat 19 best case
best case how long are we going to be
living and dealing with this virus well
the first thing to say is it's not
fading away the US has more cases than
it's had in many many weeks it if you
compare us to other parts of the world
our numbers are on the rise the European
Union you know last last week we had
25,000 cases in a particular day and the
European Union had 4,000 cases so it's
not fading away in the US it's not
fading away in the world there's
something on the what are 70 or 80
countries where the virus is on the rise
so it's a serious serious pandemic and
as w.o said we are in a new phase of
intensity in many parts of the world
vaccine development is going as quickly
as it's ever gone for any vaccine in the
world and there are a couple of vaccine
trials that are really ramping up in the
next month
so that's all good news but we don't
know yet whether and when that vaccine
will work we hope we'll have vaccine by
the end of this year but I don't think
we can count on it yet
so I think people really need to focus
on what they can do to decrease
transmission while we wait for a vaccine
and continue to do the things that we
know work in terms of preventing spread
dr. Inglesby thank you thanks for your
time on this Father's Day always good to
talk with you sir